Hello. I'm Tess Lynch,
and today we're going
to be talking about
Marjory Stoneman Douglas.
Listen. I'm gonna
transport you back in time.
Picture it. Florida.
The 1920s.
There's a special place
that is the craziest
environment that you can find
called the Everglades.
But South Florida
is experiencing
an unprecedented
population explosion.
So they're draining wetlands,
building houses.
The developers are like,
great!
I'm gonna build condos!
I'm gonna build little tiny
ticky-tacky, ticky-tacky,
ticky-tacky houses.
Hey, look at this swamp.
It's full of bullshit.
I'm gonna put a [bleep]
99¢ store on it.
But the problem with this
is that everybody's
draining the resources
of one of the most unique
ecosystems on the planet--
the Everglades!
- [laughs]
- And Ernest Coe,
and landscape architect,
realizes, like,
this place is special as hell.
I'm gonna get this place
certified as a national park
if it's the last thing I do.
And so he's flipping through
the "Important People of
Florida Directory,"
and he comes across a name--
Marjory Stoneman Douglas.
Very interesting lady.
She's like, you know,
I'm a very early supporter
of the ACLU,
and I'm supporting, you know,
women's suffrage
and civil rights,
and that's just what I do.
I'm opinionated!
And Coe's like,
this is the perfect person
to get on board with my cause.
And Coe is like, come with me
to the Everglades.
And so she goes down
to the Everglades,
and she's all in her
[bleep] pearls,
and she's wearing
her straw hat,
and she's like, yikes,
this place is too muggy,
too buggy, too inhospitable.
It's mucky and gucky!
I don't like it.
And then she's looking around
like, holy shit,
that's a crocodile holding
hands with an alligator
is what that is!
That's a manatee!
That [bleep] thing looks like
a cow under the ocean floor.
And that's a mangrove tree!
That's growing
in the brackish water
that's half salt, half fresh,
and I don't know
how that thing grows,
but it's [bleep] doing it.
I actually think
I love this place.
I'm gonna be a champion
for here.
There's a bug in front of me.
- What?
- You see that bug.
I see you seeing the bug.
- Yeah, I see the [bleep]--
- I love bugs,
but that bug I don't like.
It's like he's, like,
antagonistic. He's there.
I could grab him.
But I don't wanna kill him.
I just wanna release him
to nature.
You know what I mean?
- That's nice.
- Can we keep going?
So they go to these
town hall meetings.
The developers are like,
malls, malls, malls!
Coe and Marjory are like,
shut the [bleep] up.
Protect the Everglades.
And the legislators
are like...[stammering]
Ahh. All right.
But, I mean, it's not gonna be
so simple as like pffftt.
Coe says to Marjory,
I think they're saying
that this land
is pretty much protected.
And Marjory's like,
don't you know the government
by now? It's gonna be
a long-fought battle, Coe!
So Marjory goes down
into the Everglades,
and she spends
13 crazy long years
writing every detail down.
You know,
I'm gonna write a book!
"The Everglades:
River of Grass."
That's a good title,
God damn it.
1947, this thing is published.
Immediate best seller.
So people are like,
holy shit!
I was just sort of
thinking about my casseroles.
Now I'm a [bleep] activist!
All of a sudden, the Everglades
are really important to people
who never cared before.
And then later that year,
the first 1.3 million acres
of the Everglades
are officially desigignated--
desigignated.
♪ Designated ♪
as a national park,
just like Coe and Marjory
had wanted.
But then
Ernest Coe dies.
- Oh.
- It's so sad.
Most people could kinda
kick back.
Guess what.
She doesn't quit.
You know why?
Girl likes a challenge.
So when she hears
the Nixon administration
is planning to build Miami
Nat--International Airport
on the Everglades,
she just can't let it slide.
♪ ♪
- Would you mind if I made
your drink
just a little higher?
- I would love it.
- Is that okay?
- [snickers]
- ♪ You're simply the Tess ♪
- This is a very small
wine glass.
- Yeah. They catch up
on you, though.
- Let me know when.
Now?
Cool.
So what she does--
Marjory Stoneman Douglas
meets the Nixon administration
on the [bleep] runway.
And they're like, ugh, oh!
You're such a pebble
in my shoe.
She's a nuisance.
She won't budge.
And Nixon is like,
puhhhh. Fine!
We'll build it somewhere else.
And she goes,
hah hah hah hah hah hah hah!
I'll see ya next time,
bozos.
And she skips away.
How can you argue with
someone who's like,
don't destroy nature.
How can you?
So Marjory is looking back
at what she's done,
and she's like, holy cow,
it's the third largest
national park,
and that's nothin'
to shrug at.
I'll just keep goin'
till I die.
And she does.
In 1998, at the age of 108,
the Everglades, for a moment,
grow silent,
and there's a manatee,
and he's like,
ah...there she goes...
the mother of the Everglades.
[whispers]
Darkness.
To quote Marjory:
"Be a nuisance
where it counts.
"Be depressed, discouraged,
"and disappointed at failure
"and the disheartening
effects of ignorance,
"greed, corruption,
and bad politics.
But never give up."
Today the students
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School
carry on that idea
by turning their pain
into action.
They are the pebble
in the shoe,
they are the nuisance,
they are the people
who will not let
something so important
be taken away.
There are some things
that are too special to take.
[soft music]
- Cheers.
Be a nuisance.
Sweaty here in the Everglades.
- Very sweaty.